jean-louis quoique microbiologie ce
professeur agréé chez agrégé au
val-de-grâce fondateur de mes vaccins
point net
bonsoir jean loïc wac merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france vous avez
j'imagine suivi cette allocution d'
emmanuel macron globalement on ira dans
le détail après ce que vous êtes
satisfait en tout cas de cette tonalité
de son torrent et de ces mesures fortes
du président de la république
aujourd'hui
oui je pense que les autorités
sanitaires ont pris la mesure du
problème et le président l'a dit à
plusieurs reprises il a suivi les
conseils des scientifiques et il a
consultées de manière assez large et les
scientifiques qui ont d'une autorité sur
la question et je pense que j'ai fait
les bonnes décisions ont été prises des
décisions assez forte comme par exemple
la firme durant la fermeture de toutes
les écoles collèges lycées universités
c'est un effet décision importante qui
je crois qu'il fallait la prendre
effectivement c'était a fait partager
j'entendais encore le ministre blanquet
redire il ya quelques heures qu'il n'y
aurait pas de fermetures d'écoles en
france en tout cas pour le moment à
votre avis qu'est ce qui a fait changer
d'avis emmanuel macron sur ce plan je
sais pas qui je sais pas s'il a changé
d'avis qu'ils qui ce qu'il a dit lui en
tout cas c'est que les experts ont fait
des recommandations et qu'il s'est
appuyé sur ses recommandations
et effectivement quand on regarde quand
on écoute les experts actuellement les
épidémiologistes qui s'intéresse de près
à cette question et bien on sait qu'il
ya un point crucial c'est le confinement
la distance sociale et que pour éviter
la propagation de la maladie
il faut en effet éviter tous les
facteurs diffusion on sait que les
enfants et les jeunes adultes peuvent
être infectés manière à cette thématique
comme ils ne savent pas qu'ils peuvent
transmettre le virus et donc c'est un
facteur de diffusion important donc je
pense qu'en effet c'est de ce point de
vue là une très sage
cision même si elle est assez lourde de
conséquences mais je pense qu'il fallait
la prendre avant qu'on soit totalement
débordés parce qu'on voit que l'épidémie
progresse vite et on sait que les cas
qu'on compte aujourd'hui sont la partie
émergée de l'iceberg et biologique des
désaffections a comme un navire russe
autre recommandation de la part du
président de la république le travail à
distance d'intensification du télé
travail la limitation des déplacements
au strict nécessaire ça aussi ça nous
paraissait important oui sans relève
exactement toujours du même principe
si c'est le mot clé un augmenter la
distance sociale le confinement chaque
fois que c'est possible si l'enfant est
malade il faut absolument le garder à la
maison
donc voilà le faire tous ceux qui tout
ce qu'on peut tout ce qui est en notre
pouvoir shakoor à titre individuel et
les collectivités également pour faire
en sorte que la diffusion du virus soit
ralentie et que les hôpitaux ne sont pas
débordés par les urgences les cas graves
aujourd'hui le plus important janvier
quoique c'est clairement de comme l'a
dit le président de la république de
gagner du temps et de protéger les plus
vénérables parce que les plus jeunes
viendront ensuite fait ce qu'ils avaient
l'air de dire notamment à l'hôpital
oui c'est exactement ça parce que le
risque auquel on risque ça vous pourrez
être confrontés c'est d'être débordés ne
pas avoir assez d'oxygène de
respirateurs pour sauver des vies et
pour ça il faut aplanir la courbe le pic
d'infection et si on arrive à faire en
sorte que soient mieux réparties dans le
temps bois mieux les prendre en charge
alors la prise en charge
on a eu beaucoup de témoignages ont
peut-être moi aussi autour de vous tout
simplement des proches de personnes qui
se sentaient malades qui toussait qui
ont appelé le 15 le samu comme on nous
le
conseil sauf que l'on entend souvent
longtemps trois heures pour un exemple
proche de nous
on a ensuite conseillé à cette personne
de se diriger vers la médecine libérale
qui elle est également dépassé débordés
que doit-on faire aujourd'hui quand on a
des symptômes de coronavirus en tout cas
des symptômes qu'on a de la fièvre ou
comptons ce qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
je pense qu'il faut un effet appeler le
et on doit être guidé alors je ne peux
pas me prononcer sur les cas
particuliers que vous mentionnez mais ce
que je peux dire c'est que le 15 est
habilité à donner les bons conseils
alors si tu est une affection sensible
de gravité sans essoufflement parce que
le signe clé c'est ça c'est
d'essoufflement eh bien oui ce n'est pas
très grave si la personne doit attendre
deux trois heures
mais en effet il faut éviter ce souvent
comme je le disais tout à l'heure je
suis les enfants les jeunes adultes les
la maladie est souvent très modérée est
le principal risque associés s'est cassé
la diffusion plus que les cas de même
même s'il faut toujours être très
vigilant qui peut y avoir aussi des cas
graves chez les jeunes adultes alors en
allemagne les experts en repris
d'ailleurs par angela merkel prévoyez
que 60 à 70 personnes seraient
contaminées est ce que
selon vous c'est pareil en france est ce
qu'on peut donner ce type de chiffres
sans se tromper
vous avez dit combien entre 60 et 70
personnes seraient contaminées il paraît
en l'occurrence des allemands étaient
des médecins allemands c'est à dire 70 %
oui exactement pense oui oui oui non
vous avez 60 des personnes non encore
sans pardon pardon non mais c'est pas
grave
oui eh bien écoutez je je pense qu'il
faut être toujours très prudent quand on
donne des chiffres sur l'épidémie parce
qu'il ya de nombreux facteurs qui
peuvent moduler l'évolution d'une
épidémique et je crois que le ce qu'il
faut faire c'est le maximum à l'instant
t
aujourd'hui après faire des spéculations
sur l'avenir c'est toujours très
hasardeux et moi je resterai pas merci
en tout cas jean louis content d'avoir
été avec nous microbiologiste professeur
agrégé au val de grâce et fondateur de
mes vaccins point net merci d'avoir été
avec nous